good morning it's tuesday so sarah and i
have about 3 000 books in our library
and they are all great and i value them
all very much but today i would like to
share with you the most valuable books
in our library by the way i'm defining
value as their monetary value multiplied
by the number of tiers i would cry if i
lost the book so if a book is worth a
hundred dollars and i would cry 10 tiers
if i lost it that's a thousand points
okay so i don't really collect fancy
first editions but i do have some and
the most financially valuable book in
our library is probably this first
edition of slaughterhouse five sarah got
this from me many years ago and it's now
worth like two thousand dollars which
makes it stressful to even touch that
book is really close to my heart partly
because i ended up in kurt vonnegut's
hometown living and working in his very
long shadow and partly because when i
read it in 11th grade english it helped
bring me to life as a reader i also have
a first edition of octavia butler's
parable of the sewer which i got for 65
and is now worth quite a bit more than
that i love the cover design of this
book so so much but also it's like one
of the most important american novels of
the last hundred years so it's pretty
cool to have a first printing of it okay
two more fancy rare-ish books first this
gorgeous first edition of annie
dillard's pilgrim at tinker creek i
think about this book almost every day
and the end papers are phenomenally
beautiful and i know you're not supposed
to read fancy books but this one isn't
worth that much money because it's not
in good condition so it's also my
reading copy then there's this first
edition of mark twain's christian
science this is a late twain book
devoted to absolutely eviscerating
religion in general and christian
science founder mary baker eddie in
particular i have very complicated
feelings about the book so much so that
i wrote my college thesis about it and
then my parents gave me a first edition
of it as a graduation present so while
it would only sell for like 60 dollars
it's worth much more than that to me
speaking of which all of the most
valuable books in our library are not
financially valuable they're just
irreplaceable like this copy of toni
morrison sula is worth about two dollars
but i've been reading this particular
book since 2004 and it has all of my
like marginalia which is alternately
cringe inducing and lovely for rereading
then we have this copy of sarah's book
you are an artist i love this book and
use it all the time to help me think
creatively but this particular book is
valuable to me because sarah signed it
and the inscription is lovely so you
know how most writers use like strunk
and white style guide or the ap style
guide or whatever i use instruction
booklet written by my college professor
perry lentz it covers everything from
like m dashes to the difference between
lie and lay and it is my writing style
guide like i have large swaths of it
memorized side note over the years you
may have heard me say the social order
instead of society that is because of
instruction booklet where lentz argues
very persuasively that society as a word
obfuscates hierarchies and inequalities
that are better captured by the phrase
the social order all right it's time for
the most valuable book in our library
which i think would retail for about
seven dollars but i would cry a million
tears if i ever lost it it's the spring
and the fall a book co-written by sarah
eurestgreen and me so when we got
engaged sarah gave me this book which
contains every email we wrote to each
other during the year and a half between
when we became friends and when we
started dating last year one of the
project for awesome perks was a podcast
sarah and i made called like letters
where we analyzed some of these emails
and we're gonna do it again for this
year's project for awesome i just love
reading through this book with sarah
it's just so wonderful to have this
document that charts how we fell in like
with each other and then in love with
each other so yeah don't print your
emails except occasionally do print them
because this is my most valuable book by
a very wide margin let me know in
comments what your most valuable books
are hank i would have included one of
your books except in going through my
copies of them i realized you've never
signed one for me i'll see you on friday